welcome to this video playing oops
Mott's I cannot add someone someone
someone actually had translated this for
me I think it this is the Russian word
for Hedgehog something like that okay we
have the the nihms oh I would this line
mmm did he play that against me
someone had played this before against
me very an unambitious line okay I'm
sure that this was right I have a weird
feeling that I had this on the board
before maybe I should have maybe I
should have gone to to f6 okay
still a solid position yeah it looks a
bit threatening on g7 ah maybe I should
have I should play that yeah white has
this structural problem the pawn on c4
but it's got some activity
I'm not threatening me five if he has
got annoyed f5 and this is not really
leading to anything not sure where to
put the Queen might be five might be
might be coming maybe prepare Queen c7
I'd like to connect rooks of course
maybe Queen c7 rook F da de Xiang fa g7
does this kind of thing interesting who
tries to exchange hmm yeah that's I
cannot really take this maybe Queen D
for coming
and quit default sets that's pretty
annoying good move probably to f6 I can
defend with f6 not very very good
completely fire
I really don't see a good move here in
this position that's not very good queen
d4 is very annoying Knight a for I don't
know that this leads to okay I need to
play something yeah yeah this was clear
what else
Quincy ADA thought maybe Bishop c6
coming this all looks dangerous
I still like to play the rook and Bishop
f8 to fhe 7 maybe I can get this in
should have a g7
and queen defy probably wants to play I
can prevent it for the moment check okay
see he wants to play a rock t1 with the
tempo and then Queen before I have f6 no
nothing that makes me very enthusiastic
but 24 f6 is probably still stable opt 8
to trade all the rooks now I'm about one
minute down it's a dangerous position
24 f6 yeah maybe this is still okay I'm
interesting but I understand he wants to
get rid of this is Bishop which keeps
the position together don't really have
a good spot for it yeah white is better
you can just take and play Queen f3 for
example yeah or that one f6 not a happy
move a queenie of 3 ad was a bit more
afraid of to attack the pawn okay Bishop
g6 is not not yet a threat
if five can I do that in five to trade
off stuff maybe light squares look weak
but if he takes on c5 can have opposite
colored bishops Jack okay yeah okay I'm
position wise I'm out of the woods made
mostly I guess but the time is still an
issue the shank exchanges Queens it's
very trivial drawn in yeah this is also
a drop time warning but I am long time
check
check wasn't totally sure like the best
best setup to draw but this is pretty
safe check I can just I can just suffer
shuffle him now the problem is the time
of course should I should go to be six
actually to have to be able to take a
seven and it would have been much easier
grah I've heard I guess it's it it's
probably a draw I'm not 100 percent sure
already if he's she may be so cannot
wait you know speaking it should be a
draw here clearly but Jack not sure if
my my setup was was really the most
convincing I don't have a form of course
I can't just and this was this was a bit
stupid
I shouldn't I have I'm not sure I was I
was thinking maybe I shouldn't even take
because if I don't take and the pollen
III will be an eternal weakness but he
might have G form yeah okay I can't take
just not not a big issue
yeah maybe h5g find H form maybe this is
this is even better here this stuff he
cannot play this anyway because d5 would
drop and they have Bishop e7 and then h4
yeah this is a very clear draw he has no
way no way forward but let's check I
wasn't really in big trouble and I think
I had this before yeah it feels like
addition of maybe against the same guy
should probably do do something else
here ie five I think I overlooked the
same thing some time ago if five is just
good winning a tempo and then taking
which looks very convenient really
listen maybe just take or play Knight f6
with a very good position okay yeah here
and I'm in some trouble because it's
really active yeah this this looks
fairly logical maybe here I can do so
thing better g6 looks normal opt one
maybe
yeah compounds to play Bishop f6 yeah
maybe this is better I didn't want to do
that because it it leaves the night a
bit unstable but it's nothing really can
do here
Bishop a3 for example this is nonsense I
can play b6 and nonsense this is wrong
word I mean it's not really helping him
much queen a fire also okay yeah this is
probably a better defense
I'm Knight B 3 is a very strong move
really it removes the c5 locator yeah
tonight.a for wasn't move that I'd like
to play a comp is still on on 0.4 as
something bearable but yeah I'm in
trouble
definitely Brooksie one strong again
maybe here something better but it keeps
a big edge in the comp
laughs White's position queeg's 3 yeah I
have this problem the diagonal I have
this something I this is very very
strong compass just sort of just one
porn yeah one pawn about I don't know it
looks very very problematic I don't
think I could have defended this with
little time Jeff took here which still
with which seems to keep some edge no
idea 5 yeah what is definitely better
here
yeah I thought Queen f3 would be good
compounds to play h3 yeah maybe to head
then he switches to create switches to
Queen a3 it's being in the best move
okay I had probably the right right
feeling there why should attack the weak
upon him
you know that's a very very nice
position like this then then try to try
to continue you also have those those
kind of ideas my widest clearly bottom
here of 624 Oba Diah here I'm probably
halfway okay as I mentioned too and I
mentioned I managed to to get something
traded and okay the transformation into
those colored bishops ending this is a
thing just a draw not much that what can
do yeah
tough game thanks for watching